welcome back to CBS mornings and today
in our series protecting the planet we
find out how NASA is using powerful
Tools in space to help find solutions
back here on Earth it's the latest in
our climate report the in the latest
climate report rather the agency says
that 2022 was the globe's fifth hottest
year on record part of a long-term
warming Trend attributed to climate
change caused by human beings with this
in mind NASA is Shifting its high-tech
resources to gather more data on how our
planet is changing and has been changing
senior National and environmental
correspondent Ben Tracy takes us inside
the space program's new Earth focused
missions to help us better understand
our rapidly warming world
and liftoff when you think of NASA this
is probably what comes to mind shuttle
launches blasting astronauts into space
high-powered telescopes capturing
otherworldly images and Rovers exploring
far off planets
but with our own planet now undergoing
dramatic and devastating changes
NASA is turning its eyes back towards
Earth NASA is the tip of the spear for
climate change Randy friedl is deputy
director of earth science at NASA's jet
propulsion laboratory in Pasadena
California he points to NASA's new Earth
system Observatory a series of five
Advanced satellite missions that will
monitor nearly every aspect of our
planet from Bedrock to Atmosphere we
turn with a renewed Focus to our home
planet of Earth it will give NASA a 3D
view of how the Earth Systems are
operating and impacted by climate change
are you kind of looking at the vital
signs of planet Earth that's exactly
what we're doing and really looking at
the heartbeat of the planet just a whole
host of things that we are tracking
every single day and the liftoff in
December NASA launched a rocket from
California can carrying a satellite
called SWAT which stands for surface
water and ocean topography This 1.2
billion dollar mission is the first
radar to survey almost all of the
world's surface water nearly every ocean
river lake and stream on the planet
basically this thing can survey 6
million bodies of water every three
weeks yeah that's right it can cover
everything project scientist Paul Rosen
says SWAT will help to better detect and
plan for floods droughts and Rising Seas
which are expected to make many coastal
areas around the world uninhabitable in
the decades to come
and this is a NASA animation of its
upcoming Mission nysar scheduled to
launch next year in a joint project with
India's Space Program
[Music]
Knight will use 2
systems to track subtle changes in
Earth's surface to less than a half inch
this will allow better detection of ice
sheet collapse and the melting of
glaciers
it will track deforestation which
contributes to global warming
and also monitor groundwater supplies
and even soil moisture which can help
predict the risk of wildfires so this is
a pretty impressive piece of Machinery
it's unprecedented and we're covering
all of the land and the ice covered
surfaces every 12 days twice once when
the satellite is going up towards the
North Pole and once when it's coming
down towards the South Pole we had to
suit up that look all right good to go
good to go yeah all right and get any
dust particles blown off of us before
they would let us in here this is the
big clean room High Bay two NASA's
so-called clean room where they're
testing nice or sensitive mechanics this
is it before shipping all of this over
to India next month is this the most
advanced radar NASA's ever put up into
space yeah I'd say by far it's the most
advanced radar and NASA plans to share
the data from all of these missions with
scientists and governments to better
understand and adapt to climate change
so you've been working on this for more
than 10 years how excited are you to get
this thing up there words cannot express
how excited I am to get this thing up
there it's very exciting to me
and it's one more set of eyes in the sky
NASA will have staring back at Earth for
CBS mornings Ben Tracy Pasadena
California
so it's nice to understand what's to
come but some things you just it's a
harsh reality when you look at the
future they're not bringing back good
news they're not seeing good things and
we seem to be counting on some kind of
technological solution in the future
because we're not making changes in the
present to avoid what scientists say is
coming it sucks for the coastal
communities they're so beautiful but
there's still time for us to change
there is time to help the planet yeah
it's true